في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير الماضي قررت
روسيا اللجوء لقرار الحرب على اوكرانيا
التي اختارت مع انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
ان تكون دوله مستقله لاول مره منذ قرون
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه على حد
التعبير الكرملين كانت بدايتها بالقصف
الجوي لتتحول بعد ذلك الى تدخل بري من
اربعه نقاط استراتيجيه تشمل شبه جزيره
القرم اقليم ومن الشمال الشرقي في خاركيف
ومن الشمال باتجاه كييف مرورابيل في هذه
الحرب شكلت دعم الغربي لاوكرانيا بالاسلحه
نقطه مهمه بواسطه تزويدها باسلحه متطوره
كانت ابرزها مدافع هاودزر وصواريخ جافلين
ومنظومه باتريوت ودبابته
وايضا قاذفاته مارس الامريكيه الحرب
الدائره تسببت في اكبر ازمه اللاجئين في
اوروبا وفقا للامم المتحده تسبب القتال
بمغادره ما يقرب من ثمانيه ملايين شخص
اوكرانيا ونزوح سته ملايين اخرين داخليا
كما تسببت في قتل الاف الجنود والمدنيين
دون وجود مصادر مستقله تتحدث عن حجم القتل
الذي يقدر بعشرات الالاف من الجانبين لاول
مره منذ نهايه الحرب البارده خرج الحديث
عن استخدام السلاح النووي من قائمه
الممنوعات بل اصبح يتركز في نوع القنابل
استراتيجيه كانت او تكتيكيه
امرت وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان العامه
الروسيه بتعيين قوه الردع التابعه للجيش
في حاله تاهب قتالي عاليه
في الشق الاقتصادي عقوبات قاسيه فرضت على
روسيا قابلتها سلسله من حزم الدعم المالي
لاوكرانيا لكن التكلفه الاقتصاديه كانت
هائله بالنسبه لكياف التي رجعتها الحرب
عقودا الى الوراء